so we're staring at each other he says i
want you to know
that i was once an ss trooper wow and i
killed many gis sometimes i had to kill
them behind lines with a garat
what say you hello everyone
hola mis amigos you're listening to oh
my god hi
with me george lopez okay let's do the
show
i'm gonna go
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere
what's his name george george lopez
oh my god omg
oh my god
didn't have freshman ball they had
varsity
b's and c's right and so i'm trying for
the b team
i'm a freshman and i was the last guy
they cut from the team
and the coach just pulled me aside says
hey i gotta tell you son he says you're
good i was a catcher
he says you got good defensive skills he
says and you can hit
he said but i'm building my team on
speed it's a speed you don't have
wow so he says i'm sorry but
i'm gonna have to cut you and i was the
last guy to get cut from the team and i
never played
organized ball [ __ ] that's wow that's
crazy now you gotta signed dodgers hat
hey well good buddy of mine because i
played softball for years and my wife
there was a problem she just said hey i
was playing ball three times a week
and says can you cut down the two at
least so one of the guys i played with
guy remind me of mookie betts black guy
yep and
uh my son was a ring bearer in his
wedding married to a latina
and i was telling him yeah the doctor
said you know i'd never run i used to
wear those braces and
[ __ ] up shoes yeah when i was a kid he
said your doctor was right you never
have been able to run [ __ ]
i know i where does speed come from the
abdominal area if i was a i don't know
don't worry i didn't have that i'd never
find it
somewhere i am not in touch with yeah i
was never uh
i was good with the glove i've had a
good arm but running
no buenos all right dude what's going on
we're back
we're back this is part there's a part
two it's part two no you can i mean
you can if you like them you don't have
to we have we can we can if you guys
want we can jump right back into the
voicemails keep that how far are you
you know i always wanted to play college
you know college of the canyons over
there in santa clara
you know when i you know i usually have
envisioned things and
kind of things have come true which is
rare i think you know
i see things and when i was
playing little league in san fernando 73
that i saw myself going and playing
baseball college of the canyons
unfortunately i wasn't the third baseman
for kennedy high school because that's
what he did
he just missed it by one school but in
my head i thought i'm pretty good with
my glove hitting pretty good
you know playing pretty good in little
league and if i said you know come out
of high school i played third base san
fernando and then i thought
well college of the canyons it's not
ucla it's not notre dame
nope i never saw myself going that good
when they got out of the army i wanted
to play football
and i went and talked to one of the
coaches over at the college i was going
to rio hondo
and i said i'm a different guy you know
i'm a tour i want to do this now
and he said okay so i told my dad my dad
said hey you're not going to be a pro
football player get a job
and we talked about it and finally the
last thing he told me is okay
this is they're hiring at ford motor my
friend telling me they're hiring a ford
motor company
he says go down there reply he says if
they don't take you go play college ball
i don't you know just
get this last thing so they hired me
and had i been playing college ball
i never would have had time that you
never would have dated my girl i never
would have gotten married
yeah and uh but it's okay like they're
not good it's cool
it's yeah it's crazy all that like
sliding doors out of the movie sliding
doors
yeah right here like butterfly effect or
whatever like the little those things
end up having the craziest effect down
the line
you know when i when uh in 1888 i was
working in
in las vegas at the playboy girls of
rock and roll my grandfather just died
and these girls that were in that were
singers in the
in the band said we're going to go to
the riviera because there's this
director
this [ __ ] doggy
if you saw she unplugged the sign the
atc signed back here a second ago right
here
can you put a dog to sleep before he's a
year old whoa sometimes
now we're talking about hateful comments
he's still eating the hey come on hey
that's tape bro
come on what are you doing it's like he
doesn't know what tape it
what was i saying i forgot oh uh 88
rock and hard rock rock and roll the
girl's new director
over at the riviera oh so so
so see we met these guys you know
working on this movie one guy's director
at the riviera
we're at the maxim so i wasn't gonna go
it's after the show so i probably like
12 30
in the morning and and i went and i met
this dude rich corral
he was uh um
on leave it to bieber as a kid like i
forget what kitty was
uh richard he was richard on leave it to
beaver so
his his brother worked in the industry
and then he was directing this movie
called ski patrol
and i went over there and he saw me and
we talked and i said you know i ski and
he started laughing
and i got a part in that movie and if i
hadn't gone with those girls i never
would have met the dude that did ski
patrol in 89
he got me into the union i was on a
movie set
it came out it didn't do well but it's
always been out and it's like that
if i had my instincts were i never
wanted to go anywhere
and then after the show i went because i
must have felt instinctually to go and
then you see this guy and these girls
are off with some other dudes
and me and him are talking and boom
that one thing like changed everything
yeah yeah
all right that's great that's what
cheese told me you get one thing and
then you get everything off the one
thing
i love it you guys do some voicemails
here
dip right into the advice
all right
honestly sniper one come in
[Laughter]
kill we're down already helicopters down
hey saber-tooth saber-toothed seven two
one
come in gilly how do you get this
somebody
turn around oh there we go okay
he must be an earbud guy okay here we go
here we go devil dog leader i'm back in
flight
all right let's hear some [ __ ] all
right some more questions
hey george it's terry from texas i have
a question
why is it that every guy i meet i am
um divorce have my house and my kids
whatever that life
every guy whatever take care of them
like i'm their mother or something is it
just me
or is it something i'm putting out okay
thanks love you
bye okay that that is a great question
on a lot of levels man you know lee
travino who i love
my idol like my uncle my father
he he calls his wife mom and i think she
i don't think she calls them dad i don't
know
i don't know i i just think and
sometimes in relationships they go
mother i'm home
yeah totally not my
my wife calls me papa and i call her
nana now
so we just that's a little that's like
that [ __ ] uh
on netflix where the people dress up
like little animals
which one sexy as [ __ ] or what's the
name of that show it just came out oh
yes have you heard about this no no okay
like you would dress up with like a bear
what animal would it be like a
prosthetic like a
a bear pasta penguin lion vibe
a penguin a little penguin huh
like a little uh baby kangaroo you could
probably dress them up
that's hilarious okay so i found i found
the description so
most probably pass with that little
kangaroo so most people would want to
look their best from meeting potential
dates for the first time
because there's nothing like love at
first sight right not for the people
participating on sexy beasts
who seem to be more concerned with
personality than how a potential mate
looks
the dates are all transformed into
animals and other creatures through the
use of prosthetics
and remain in costume throughout the
dates after the featured dater makes his
or her selection the costumes are
finally removed
and it's at that point that this is
really to see if the choice they made
based on personality matches up i've
seen the trailer
in my day you just lied to her until she
found out yeah
you don't wear [ __ ] rubber nose i
didn't know i didn't you know what
i didn't realize it was that i thought
it was people that had fetishes that
dress up like [ __ ] rabbits and [ __ ]
that
that looks interesting that's a
brilliant idea right they're wearing
prosthetics
almost like a mass singer yeah smash
singer but a little more disturbing
and do they have sex like they make out
with like a [ __ ] rhinoceros and a
[ __ ] dove
i don't know if they're able to do that
but they go on a date at least they go
try and hang out and they do all sorts
of stuff but you're looking like the
creature from the black lagoon
or like something from like a star trek
alien which one would be yours
um oh i'd be uh you'd probably be who
would it be some sort
i think no
[Laughter]
so i don't the 48 year old she's got to
be looking good men are still after her
she wants
she's into nurturing her kids she's used
to nurturing men
that's what she knows so what does you
know
don't they always nurture you like
they're trying to raise you again or is
that just
that that's her motherly instincts you
know and
and some people like that and some
people just take advantage
guys just take advantage of that so they
have somebody that takes care of them
they don't have to put out that much
well
that's what you don't want that's a good
point that's a great point i think i
think that that's what you don't want is
you don't want somebody that says that
and then you know like me last week you
never get out of the house you don't
want to work
they cook for you they clean for you
like that's that's way different just
taking advantage of it they're just
looking for something free
yes so what would we say yeah no so i
mean if she's if she doesn't want people
to mend to treat her like a mom
yeah so yeah yeah like
exactly so she already knows she sees it
and and she shouldn't you know it's not
her that wouldn't be her instinct was to
pursue it so
that was the easy one [ __ ] 10 minutes
of going around there
okay there we go next stop
hey what's up george this is uh jonathan
calling out here in the midwest
uh i got a question i want to know if
there's any musicians or celebrities
that you looked up to growing up
and you met them later on and you were
you were kind of let down or it just
wasn't what you expected
you know your whole life being a fan of
them love to hear what you have to say
love you george big fan take it easy
there you go celebrities or musicians
you met who were not
what you thought they would be maybe
good maybe bad well helping it for both
you know uh she always said this is kind
of right in my hand
it's that kind of right in my alley you
know i it's funny man
you know if i look at my pictures it's
it's crazy who
are the people that i'm ted nugent you
know we love ted nugent back then you
know he's
far right like radically right
death threat right i'm death threat left
but
when when i got my
that the secret service was going to
come in and talk to me at my house
because of what i said
ted nugent was also investigated by the
secret service and
he sent me a text going if you need any
tips on how to talk to the
secret service let me know good dude
so politically opposites but still
friends
and people every time i post a picture
or if i did i really don't but i take
all the guys i went to high school with
he treats him great we've all been fans
forever and politics
makes people think that because i like
ted nugent for his music and his
relationship
what i would consider a friend 12 years
that
this ideal of [ __ ] you know he's so
far right
that i should hate them or you know and
i don't i don't do it like that
politics is separate yeah they are very
still did stranglehold cat scratch fever
come on man
great white buffalo tango
and i i've never heard him to me
i don't know many celebrities i've met
celebrities
nobody's ever treated me bad nobody i've
never struck up a friendship
as much as with george yeah george is a
big time
celebrity and it's just great and that's
true
no no it's awesome for me man it's like
you have somebody you know everybody my
age is over there in woodland hills in
the
society home
well and you know maybe you don't want
to put anyone on blasters no [ __ ] that
but
you did meet who was really ringo starr
i was at the opening of
the uh uh hard rock cafe on hollywood
boulevard a lot of people were there
and ringo was in this vip area right
next to me and i asked him if i could
have a picture
and he said no hey and this is right i
mean people say picture of me
you know i rarely say no but i get it
you know he's a [ __ ] beetle like you
know everybody must
you know eric estrada told you know one
time
here let's see if she stays there come
on
all right that's pretty good we got it
those are all pretty good questions man
yeah we've got uh we've got a bunch more
well listen
also i would say this also you know like
i don't think i'll be involved in any
relationships
between now and my demise whenever that
may be but
the signs are always there like when you
are with somebody
and you make concessions for some
behavior that
otherwise maybe you wouldn't stand for
all right
and now the all the weed in me is
getting all leveled out
about one of these that freaking
position all right there you go now we
get the good advice good now we get the
ring
but you know what i'm saying it's like
it's and you see it you know the the
i think the toughest thing and i don't
really see the cases where it's harder
for a woman than a man i think guys
you know can get dismissed it hurts more
than i believe that it might hurt a
woman i don't know i'm not a woman but
i see them put under the [ __ ] every
night every time they dress up shiny
they're looking for something
that [ __ ] big kick that big chill so
um in that like you see like the
problems that i had before i got married
were the bigger problems i had
after i got married i mean i wasn't
anybody new you just got kind of you
know
blamed for an accelerated behavior where
before
you know yeah no but the signs are all
on the wall
and you would see like you see something
you walk in you go okay this person that
this dude person doing something and you
know
already that you don't like it and then
you go in
and then it doesn't it doesn't work out
yeah i mean lord knows i'm no expert but
i do know the problems that like
you are working on and you think a
relationship might fix yeah the
relationship will not fix them they will
just get amplified because now there's
another person involved
that's right and having a baby no i'm
kidding
yeah that's how you save the marriage um
all right
you got uh can you guys do a couple more
let's do them yeah come on
okay can i play mayan's message this
might be oh yeah yeah
nobody nobody's up to the whole time
nobody knows what this is
okay so i just saw your tick tock oh my
god
[ __ ] hilarious um it's doing really
well
which i think is showing us at least
that's how i'm interpreting it that we
really need to step up our tick tock
game especially since
um it's gonna be a huge part of the show
i just read
the pilot i thought it was really good i
don't know what you think
[ __ ] kids oh my god can you believe
hey can you believe that this [ __ ]
kid man was like five years old my show
started
and she's in this show with me like we
have a deal with nbc and she's like
i just read the pilot i don't know i
think it's okay
[ __ ] come on man have you talked
about the show on air before
no i don't know do you want to tell uh
tell the people no no not right now i'd
rather tell people
when i'm not 0.000
fair enough fair enough um what was the
tick tock in question by the way she
said she saw the tick tock
she's calling in response to a text
house all right well she did a tick tock
i guess of
some somebody that she met and says like
this person is not like my dad we just
[ __ ] got you in
and then i i did my retort
you know one of my daughters told me one
time i find the reason i'm having
trouble
finding the right guy to meet my
expectations is because i keep measuring
them up to
my dad i think that's i think that's
another thing too
that's an issue that's a daddy issue but
you want somebody to be
of the of the integrity of that that
that's sort of like a daddy standard
than a dad yeah well no the intake but
that's
that's a cause i mean you're somebody
that's younger you look at somebody
that's
you know have 20 years or more of
experience and you go okay
he lived a great life respectful did
what he did but
you know you tell somebody who's like in
their early 20s like
well he's you know he's lived more than
i have
you know she did this one right here
[Laughter]
when nothing about him reminds me of my
dad
and she's going crazy she's dancing like
this [ __ ] guy showing
man it's kids if i try to take her back
to
14713 hagar i don't think she makes it
out of the [ __ ] morning do a the
morning dew would still be on the grass
and she'd be running home
that's it that's the reality i look at
some of these things now
they wouldn't last man that day my
grandfather got up at like
[ __ ] 4 45 5 o'clock in the morning
turned every light on
made every [ __ ] sound and noise
didn't give a [ __ ] that
i was sleeping right you know five feet
away or that i had to go to school
nothing they start the car right by the
[ __ ] window they don't roll it back
or be considerate
and [ __ ] we all turned out all right
i told the former sheriff of l.a county
sure uh lee baca he had just been
elected the sheriff he hadn't even taken
the oath of office yet now his master's
ceremony is at the dinner he was at
and he got up there and he told the
story about how when he was a kid in his
east l.a lincoln heights where he was
from neighborhood how he can remember
back the music back then spade cooley
skipped to my lou
and he walked away after at night that
microphone and i said i got to be honest
with you sheriff
you'd have played that [ __ ] in my
neighborhood we'd have stolen your lunch
he sounds like our age he's a little
older than us is he still locked up
yeah any time now he's he's getting out
he's due to get out
you're so you're you're like when you
were in the military you're in the army
yes and then when you're in the
sheriff's you're 100 of the sheriffs 100
like you you don't if anybody were to to
bad-mouth
the military it would be like
bad-mouthing your service right which i
oh yeah but any anybody no but i mean
sure you know because they're
you know there is a lot of people don't
talk about
what what families go through when when
one of the young kids is like male or
female is defending the country
you know and and that we're safe
every day pretty much i mean from our
problem isn't coming from other
countries the problems coming from
within our own country
with the shootings and all that stuff
but um
when i went to walter reed to go see the
the soldiers that were sick in 2004
god bless you i went every time i went
to washington dc
and my book had come out and i went over
and signed books and there was a lot
there was a lot of them
a lot of them there uh and uh
one of the stories was there was this
girl in in the shorts and the army
t-shirt
and she is walking across like a lit
bridge
like a from one building to the other
and and she's very attractive it was
probably in her early 20s and she's
walking
kind of you know she got here with a
shot grenade and it [ __ ] with her
spine
so so she walks like this and
we saw her and she was coming to visit
somebody that she didn't know because
he had been injured he was in there i
mean he got blown up man like
you know they taped the hat you know and
that she knew that nobody was going to
see this guy
and she was going to see him and spend
time with him because she knew that he'd
be alone otherwise
and i mean that is something that i
don't think
people people do that god bless you you
know i don't
i don't think a girl like that that you
know she was injured in combat
the [ __ ] shot grenade flux with all
your nerves right yeah
it makes you you know nervous system
yeah anything you mess up your spine too
yeah
mess up everything and you know walking
across that thing
and going over and the
things that people sacrifice so that you
know you and i can
enjoy that but it should never be lost
on anybody even people that mean harm
that
you wouldn't be able to do what you did
are doing in another country they cut
your [ __ ] hands off
you know an eye for an eye you're done
mcafee died in a spanish that spanish
prison land prison
yeah they were going to extradite him
they beat the probably the [ __ ] out of
that dude before he got extra dude like
you're not gonna
it's a different world when you're out
it's a different world out there
when i saw midnight i've been there
been there seen it done it people don't
realize how good they have it
you know they they really kind of you
know they don't realize how
you know you're free to be whatever you
want to be pretty pretty much i mean
there's people that aren't going to ever
accept people for
who they really are but you should you
don't worry about it like social media
but there's so much [ __ ] going on that's
about color when you think
[ __ ] 50 [ __ ] five years ago we had
riots in l.a
it's the same it's almost the same [ __ ]
in another cycle man
like you know i thought when i was you
know starting at 18 doing stand-up and
by the time i got to be 60 i wouldn't
have to worry about getting the [ __ ]
secret service to visit me at my house
because i said something that was a joke
and not you know
you know when you're trying to tell
people they're trying to get all of
those
when you tell the people that are haters
about the problems you know how good
they have it
and you tell them what you've really
seen they don't believe you anyway
are you are you serious did that really
happen are you going to try and convince
me that that's where it really was
they have no idea so i i don't i think
the i don't address them i don't talk
about it i think the worst thing
is the imagination like you know it's
like when you
like a girl and you don't see her
anymore and you see a picture where you
already see her blowing like three dudes
what the [ __ ] yeah the lamp lighter
right there on magnolia
you know what i mean like your mind
takes over stuff that you shouldn't
[Laughter]
not you because you've been married for
uh 50 years but me
or grant too i mean with anything too
it's like the more
the more unknown there is the easier it
is for your mind to go crazy and just
kind of picture oh
the worst thing the buddhists say
replace a bad thought with a good
thought
you know probably the best one of the
best conversations i ever had
was uh when i was in germany and i met a
guy named hair foster ling and their
foster lang was the owner of a
restaurant on the bottom and it was a
disco on top it was the only one in the
little town smallest town
in uh germany legal size town and a
little place called year was that
that would have been 1970
and i was one of maybe four to five gi's
that would go to this small town because
everybody went to
wurzburg where all the [ __ ] and the
bars and everything was so i used to go
over here
a guy introduced me to split and i liked
it very friendly people
and he came over through an interpreter
and he wanted to sit right in front of
me just like you are right now in front
of me
and the interpreter is to my left
and she says her foster lien would like
to talk to you and i said okay
so we're staring at each other he says i
want you to know
that i was once an ss trooper wow and i
killed many gis sometimes i had to kill
him behind lines with a garat
what say you and i looked at him
never taking my eyes off him i said
i just came back from vietnam where i
had to kill vietnamese people
and vietnamese people tried to kill me
i don't hate all vietnamese people and i
hope i hope
that all vietnamese people don't hate me
war is hell and there are no winners
nobody wins you did what you thought was
right for your country
as i did what i thought was right for my
country
and that's what happened and that's the
way life is
and he just said this is good my throne
that's just good mine throwing
next thing i know he's standing up stops
the music
and the interpreter says oh my god gil
you must stand so i stand up next time
and he announces everybody in this guest
house
in this disco that i'm his friend if
anybody doesn't like it come up one at a
time or everybody who wants we'll find
them all
and fortunately they they all started
clapping and then he bought a round of
drinks for everybody in the house
and come to find out his daughter was
married to a lieutenant
in the united states army he had never
been allowed to step inside
here fosterling's house he says he knows
not what combat is about
he's young he's naive
he doesn't know he's no good you might
throw in
man this guy gave me rides he just like
giving me the key to the city
i could do no wrong in that place
anymore
and so it was just a conversation
between myself and
former guy was that ss i got chills
jesus that was incredible
so uh here fossil is probably dead now
i'm gonna go ahead and say that i don't
think i've ever heard
a story quite compelling as that in my
life no
dude that is that is nuts
i wouldn't even tell you about any of
the other things i already got i heard
he got in trouble for the third grade
kids
that was me that wasn't with me though
but but the fact that um
you know there were thousands of ss
right so
i mean i think documentaries you know
they don't show the numbers of
of that but a lot of those dudes they
got i think the america
alleged might have brought a lot of
people from germany engineers and stuff
too
definitely science i don't know if they
did a lot of them got away with it he
had
uh a slew of american cars wow
you know that that he had in his
property yeah and so he was probably no
good in his day but it was during the
war and that's what he did and that's
what was going on
you know man that's a trip huh isn't
that a trip like the dude
and you answered the question sure
honestly he knew that you weren't
bullshitting him yeah
he knew that wasn't [ __ ] he said
what say you and i well here it is
because i
i was really everything's going through
my heart i said no this guy's getting
ready to whack me or you know something
else
but he was like the big chin going on
campus there
[ __ ] man and everybody bowed to him
and so once he gave me the key to the
city that was it i could do no wrong
beautiful that's crazy honestly yeah did
you um
do you feel like that was your thought
had you ever like put it in those
words or those terms before or did you
kind of had you articulated that to
someone else or even to yourself or was
it kind of like okay
now i'm being asked this question in
this intense circumstance and that's
when you came
nobody had ever asked me i never thought
about it but in thinking about when he
said what say you
yeah i had to think about what war
really meant to me and and it's
the very truth you know they're guys
that are fighting in afghanistan when
they come back they're bitter they're
angry
but i hope they don't hate all afghani
people and i hope all afghani people
donate him
i just got a letter a message today
from a uh lady from turkey
that said i'm from turkey have you heard
about turkey
what do you think and so i don't know
that much about turkey other than there
are a lot of turmoil
so all i could say without taking
because i don't know what side she's on
with this
yeah i said all i can say is i have i
don't know that much about your country
and i pray that you were safe and
healthy
and you continue with a good life
and then i'll hear her you know now
she's got it she's got a time taker
waiting on what y'all [ __ ] doctor
philo here
yeah no wonder your daughter's having
trouble look at these answers
let me start your car for you when we
get out of here because you know you
never know
oh my goodness well i so i can i ask a
voice mail question i have a question of
my own
based on something you guys said earlier
um i mean talking a little bit about
whether the younger generation or
raising kids or whatnot but like and
everybody thinks that you that makes you
seem like you're ancient it just makes
you seem
like you're wise people used to have
[ __ ] wisdom and now they're like ah
[ __ ] him he thinks he knows everything
yeah if i can't put it in a tweet come
on is it wise
but anyways if somebody's older that's
giving you advice that you've seen
i would think you know somebody would
would want to take it
sure i mean somebody gave me some advice
in the early 90s
and he said hey man you know there's
nothing about your act tells me anything
about you
i changed it up and you know everything
changed
yeah um but to sort of like connect the
dots like what i'm thinking is
and i hear this a lot among people
who've achieved success whether in
hollywood or any any sort of realm of
life like you have gail
um you probably you know a lot of us
have struggles growing up things we
never want to repeat but things that
sort of
made us the way we are yeah and i think
for our kids you know
i imagine we all sort of want the best
for our kids and we want them to
on one level not have those struggles
but at the same time like
those struggles made you guys for
example who you are so how did you
i mean what are your thoughts on that
how did you contend with that when
raising a family all that sort of stuff
i
i don't want my kids to go through a
struggle but i don't want my kids
to think that life is easy my daughter
received a ticket
so i knew she'd received a ticket it was
at a pomona court
so i asked her one day i said hey did
you take care of that ticket
she says yes i said well what's this
right here and it was on top
i said you haven't taken care of this
yet i said come on let's go
put her in the car we went down to
pomona court i said you wait out here i
went back because i knew everybody
pomona court i went
went to one of the clerks back there i
said hey look let's take it out he
looked it up he said well gil
it's not here i don't know what's going
on i said well let me check this deck
it's oh you're lucky he was going to
warrant oh my god
he says okay you want me to get a uh
he says you want to bring your daughter
back we'll just take care of it right
now
and or do you want me to get a
continuance on i said get a continuance
he said sure if she's here you know she
bailed do it i still
get a so continuance got a continuance i
said okay let's go
went outside told my daughter let's go
says
what happened i said well your ticket
was going to warrant
she says well did you take care of it or
can i take care of it right now i said
no
i said you're going to come back on your
own and you're going to stand in line
like everybody else
and you're going to take care of your
own ticket not with me
so i made her learn the process
no i'm not here to coddle you you know
maybe you'll think a little wiser next
time and be careful
so that's what i did and i've tried to
uh my kids knew all of them knew
don't drop the guild career card right
just do what you got to do you messed up
you pay for yours and if i if i ever
would have gotten caught
for anything i've done i've done it
i admitted i'm not going to fight it not
technicality not this not
i did it okay i'll take my punishment
fortunately
i didn't get gone no but i think it's
it's tough to have somebody
like to not do it for her because you
know people would expect that
did you go to the bathroom she might
have
no that was me
oh goodness uh yeah so so you know
i think that that if you're able to help
they would expect the help but it's also
probably better and difficult to let
them do something on their own because
you kind of [ __ ] almost feel like you
want to do everything for them
yeah right they they they've got to do
it on their own they've got to learn
or else all right well i mean what's
your experience with that
sort of thing george like has that been
what's that for
helping out your kids yeah um
[Music]
i i don't know man i mean that's a
you know i didn't have my father you
know my father i guess what
the stories he left when i was two
months so when mine was two months i
looked at her and i thought you know
she's still in the crib and i thought
how could somebody leave manchester you
bounce on this
this like right here and i just think
it's all been kind of tough so
the the you know somebody always walks
you know all the people in the summer
that you would see that would walk
barefoot and you're like man i can't
walk barefooted
10 feet and there's people that just it
builds up that tough skin
and i think you know naturally by by
section of life elementary school junior
high high school
doing a stand-up and working during the
day like it's all been compartmentalized
so it doesn't really kind of
you know you kind of feel what was in my
20s now
probably because i've all kind of been
blocked out
yeah they worked in one and one degree i
do help them out
if they have trouble i can see they're
having trouble financially you know
oh yeah and i help them out uh
i've never taken rent from them when
they stay with me
they give me money
and for a while i put in an envelope
when they're time to leave
all that money you gave me here it is
you know i don't take
money from them and help them out
financially if i can
watch a [ __ ] pedicle junction
[Laughter]
all right totally that one remember that
young man in the locomotive [ __ ] joe
all right
all right uh total vibe [ __ ] you want to
go back to voicemails all right i got
some lighthearted ones here
here we go yeah how about some [ __ ]
lighthearted that's what i was thinking
yeah how about we got real we got some
lighthearted ones
here we go oh my god
hi hey george my name is kevin i love
the show i watch it every night after
work
and my question to you is how was it
working with
i believe her name is benita moreno or
aka your mom on the show
because every time you disrespect her
like calling her an old bat
or like you know just stuff like that
out those were those were the best
moments for me
so yeah my question to you is how was it
working with their like how
like how many like would you guys break
when you're disrespecting her because it
was like too funny or
etc you know and he sort of goes out
what a [ __ ] variety
yeah um
you know it's almost 20 years that my
show started uh
2022 march and march 2022
20 years wow so that lady belita that
played my
grandmother went to lunch with my
grandmother
and then she said oh your grandma was
talking to me about how proud she is of
you how much she loves that what the
[ __ ]
i go she never tells me right they too
didn't you say your dad told everybody
i don't know what the [ __ ] that is like
how do you say oh my grandson is
you know he's got his own show on abc
and this and that
and then when i was with her she'd be
like oh if i would have known i was
going to take this long i would
i [ __ ] wouldn't have come over here
you're like how do you how was that
i guess in their upbringing i guess
right when nothing's ever good you how
do you tell somebody
that they did something good when you
don't yeah and i said i sat through a
[ __ ] recital at
cal state northridge for a [ __ ] 12
hours until i was dying
we went over there when miami was a
little dancer you don't know what time
she's going to dance a [ __ ] ant has
another at nine in the morning and it
goes to like
seven at night and then maya didn't have
to dance till like 5
15 in the afternoon i'm there at [ __ ]
9 a.m i'm like what the [ __ ]
and every little [ __ ] kid out there
and they're not good they're not gonna
[ __ ]
they [ __ ] run off like [ __ ] little
chickens everybody just take off
the one that touched me the most matter
of fact i gave him a standing ovation
uh at this recital there was one where
all of a sudden they were surprised
there were about 10 dads that got up
there and did a dance
with their children oh wow so my hats
were off to the dads because they had to
be
embarrassed they had to work hard to get
it because it was a choreographed dance
and it was nice and when it was i was
the first one up
not for the kids but for the fathers
yeah they they deserved everything you
got oh that's great they'll make you do
all that [ __ ]
you know what let me say one thing about
that damn recital
you're trying to save it that those were
just my opinions no this is
one piece of [ __ ] while i was inside the
recital
my car my my car was parked right out in
front
somebody decided they'd go by and look
at the mirror you know how mirrors
rotate and move
so somebody went and moved it like to
look at themselves
and they broke my mirror oh [ __ ]
and so now we're looking probably pretty
close to about a seven hundred dollar
bill i'll take it to the car
the dealer tomorrow wow on your on your
car they turn that yeah that
that's pretty well built i want to say
what car there's a pretty well big car
to
yeah and they've moved that way it's not
like when we were yeah
oh this is recently they turned oh yeah
just happened oh yeah
and and somebody did it just because
they want to make sure their mascara was
on right or you know they're
whatever it was they did it they broke
it
and then they just walked away from it
there's no scratches no nothing they
just got it and they twisted it like
those mirrors fold in and pull down yeah
yeah
and so they popped it out it
it won't go in the lock position anymore
the motor won't move the
i couldn't it's useless i borrowed my
wife's car to come down here today
that that's uh i think that's going to
be more than 700 homes
you know so we're talking about the mo
like a motor
yeah every everything's done i i was
really upset about it i'm
i'm thinking 700 but i called up the
insurance company i got a 250
deductibles
but wouldn't they see it is there any
cameras around there no the only cameras
are inside the
recital where nobody pays attention this
was uh
legally parked on the street right in
front
in parking lanes and um
i'll pay the 250 is it a woman or a man
it's a woman men don't give a [ __ ] they
look like
that's easy all right go ahead granny
looking at your watch by the way
i buzzed nothing nothing personal
another another lighthearted one here
question for george
george oh my god
been there i've been trying to buy your
beer all freaking week
i can't buy this [ __ ] nowhere man where
the hell do i get this [ __ ] i tried
ordering on land i can't get it nowhere
and you call george bender you have a
good day that's it
that's his question we're going to get
this big question is where to get the
george lopez
come over here i think you can order it
online
don't they have a trader joe my daughter
says hey i saw it
i said buy it that's probably one of the
employees drinking it is there anyone
out in the wild i know what's happening
yeah yeah food for less there you go so
there's your answer
if you're not near a food for less go
check and also i think you can order it
online i think people will send you
will send it to you online there you go
all right let's uh let's do one more
before we get out of here
oh my god hi hey george this is dylan
from
fresno california i just want to tell
you that last
episode it creeped me the [ __ ] out but
anyway
on a more positive note i want to ask
you
uh what's uh a crazy experience you had
on psychedelics where
whether it was mushrooms acid i just
want to know like what did you see what
you experienced
let me know thank you that you know i
don't think a lot of podcasts would get
that question
yeah when i worked during the day uh in
1982 i worked at night like 81
82 i did acid at lunch with uh this guy
rich
that lived in north lunchtime that's uh
and now you that guy and i
used to work together oh god forget his
last name uh
he's to roller skate at balboa uh park
like in dolphin shorts
what is in the early 80s you know wonder
woman and a bucket piece company all
that [ __ ]
so so he would get chicks and uh
uh he was telling me that he was dating
this latina
and then i went to his apartment he was
done like receded in all this apartments
and then
the girl and her friend were over there
the girl he was dating said to a friend
i'm just going out with him because
he pays for everything and you know it
gives me money in spanish
so i told rich you know what i heard and
every time i've done that i never talked
to the guy again
he got pissed off because she convinced
him that i was lying
i've done it three times in my life and
all more for three
[ __ ] dog i'm gonna drop off by
heaven's helper
[Music]
okay gail anything for you any
psychedelic no no no no no
we don't wanna get i don't know no drugs
in my life but in in
um in vietnam i mean
man it's even hard to talk about that
that
i don't think you know was much of a
fought in the city no
right i don't think those guys were out
there
i mean did they move guys in and out by
helicopter if you were out there for
like a week
yeah yeah guys were moved in and out all
the time and the guys in the field used
a lot of dope
you know when they were out there you
know i had nothing more to do you know
other than they had to be
watchful of everybody yeah but and and i
just found out
that one of my pilot not my pilot but i
found out one of the pilots that flew in
my group
was an alcoholic and i didn't know that
and if i didn't know
and he never flew i never flew with him
but i wouldn't have flown with him if
i'd have known he was loaded
because you need two people no i know
man yeah
i mean that's and so we didn't end the
back no drugs
no and how about this how about that
that helicopter's not even really that
high off the ground
and at times they were as close to
[ __ ] hand-to-hand combat
sure we we were we were close she looked
sometimes you landed in the boonies
you're fighting you're
you're shooting it's just it was fun
to see that stuff you know it's crazy
yeah that's
all right what was the question again
there you go that was asking about crazy
psychedelic
experiences oh yeah that was i think
acid what was that the troons that was
that that was true
no that was acid is that lsd you said
that you did for that one
that was acid and then i did shrooms one
time and uh we were in the car
just you know laughing with all the
[ __ ] windows that rolled up of course
[ __ ] dying in there breathing and
then we'd go in the house
and and there was a bugs bunny picture i
think that like
it was peter laurie's head but it was
like five times bigger than
the regular head remember that cartoon
peter lauren yeah i wish i would uh
i think yeah i wish i had a wrap
something like that and then
i walked in and there was a dude that
had an oversized head on the couch
and i said i wish i had a rabbit and
then all the dudes started
i just remember you laughing the chinese
people walking down the street
every time man every time i'm out of my
mind i always see the
funniest [ __ ] but uh uh and where do you
have enough mushrooms where you are
getting like real crazy hallucinations
or you're just having a really good time
when i was working during
at night the clock melted and
all that [ __ ] that people would walk
by and there'd be like a blur behind
them
better him than me bro man that's
awesome man and i worked in the middle
of the night didn't
i get out of there like probably 6 15 or
something damn
[ __ ] who pays somebody to do asset
people in northridge california
what else that does keep leaving
voicemails we love getting to do these
on the show
uh ask ask questions again you know also
if you leave your
number in the voicemail we can't air it
just for oh it's so tracy don't leave
your number it shows up on the info
whatever so
leaving his voicemails though the
numbers on screen if you want to read it
george
gil 818 533 1843 on your radio dial give
us a call
tell it all listen i've got this before
you go
knx it's been a great day for me i have
a clayton kershaw autographed
military hat they do those signed by uh
clayton himself
from george lopez and
i've got a picture up there with george
the drawing
that's just everything is almost in zoot
suit and stand
the liver over on the on the right
you